-This is now --
We're a few weeks after
he signed the order
to stop the family separations.
They gave themselves
a deadline of this Thursday
to reunite all the families.
Where are we at right now
in that?
-So let's talk about this.
There, today, right now,
as we sit here,
2,551 kids were ripped away
from their parents
by the Trump administration,
and we should keep saying
over and over again,
till every one of these kids
is accounted for,
that this is not something
that had ever happened before.
It was a policy
that was put into place
to systematically take these
kids away from their parents.
It's a crisis on the scale
of a natural disaster
that was manmade
by the Trump administration.
This is a crisis
of their own creation.
Thursday is the deadline.
They're now saying
that something like 900
of the 2,551 have been reunited,
but they're also saying
over a third
may never, ever be reunited,
or, at least,
it's gonna be very complicated
to put these people
back together.
And we just have to continue
to demand answers
from the administration,
because none of these kids
should have been separated
in the first place.
-Now, that failure
to reunite the children,
is this a byproduct
of how terribly planned
this was to begin with?
-Yeah, absolutely.
There was never a plan.
First of all, some of
the shelters that I went to --
and I went inside
some of these places --
It was the most
harrowing experience
as a father of a young kid,
like you,
that I've ever seen in my life.
The shelters, for the most part,
take good care of the kids.
But they didn't know
these kids were coming,
separated from their parents.
The thing that disgusts me,
and I will never forget,
is that they took these kids
away from their parents
and put them in cages.
And I was one of
the small group of journalists
that got to go inside the
border patrol processing station
in McAllen, Texas,
and see these little kids
sitting around
under a watch tower,
playing by themselves,
because of the idea
that Donald Trump thought it
would scare other people
from coming into this country.
And now,
because there was no plan
to ever put it back together,
you could have kids that their
parents were already deported,
and they may never
see them again.
-There's this sense now that,
you know,
they're trying to fix it.
Do you think
they're trying to fix it
because they realized
how awful an act it was
in the first place,
or do you think
they're just trying to fix
what has become a PR disaster?
-No.
And I'll tell you something.
I saw Sean Spicer
in this building.
-Oh, I'm sorry.
-Yeah, exactly. Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
I saw him in the building
the other day.
And he was -- I asked him.
I said,
"What'd you think about it?"
And he said, "It was a mess."
And he was saying it was a mess
just like the Muslim ban
was a mess.
Because it wasn't
well-thought-through.
Not because this was inhumane
to take kids away
from their parents,
not because --
and that's the same thing
with putting them back together.
Not because
we feel bad about it
but because we just kind of
messed up and it looked bad.
And the President admitted that.
When we were down there,
from day one,
when we were in the shelter
in Brownsville,
to day seven, I think it was,
that he signed the executive
order to put them back together,
he basically said,
"I saw you guys on TV.
I saw the writing,
I saw the pictures,
and that's sort of
why we did this.
It didn't look that good."
-Yeah.
You're doing incredible work.
Thank you so much
for continuing it.
It's obviously very exciting
for me to see you
because I've been following
the work you're doing on TV.
Other people
are excited to see you
because they think
you're someone else.
-Yeah, that's true.
J.J. Abrams.
-J.J. Abrams.
[ Laughter ]
Here, why don't you
hold that up for us.
Because I will say --
-Yeah, go right over there.
-I'm not, uh...
-Yeah.
-I'm not nearly as rich.
In fact, I'm not anywhere close.
"I would love to have
the J.J. Abrams money,"
is what I say to when people
come up to me on the street.
So, J.J., hit me up.
-Yeah, there you go.
Yeah, thank you very much
for being here.
-Can I have this?
-Yeah, you can have that.
That's the least we can do.
-Thank you very much.
Okay, thank you.
-Hey, thanks for being here,
Jacob.
Keep up the great work.
I really appreciate it.